simone and jonathan will you two be back
for more bridger tim i think we we
intend to be at every wedding and and uh
yeah
yeah absolutely we'll be we'll be there
for the siblings you honestly just did
that i believe i did
how ready are you for the world to
finally see season two yeah we're ready
you know what it's like coming together
and doing this junket is brilliant
because we've after such an amazing year
last year working really hard and
telling these amazing stories again just
makes it feel more real so yeah we're
excited for the world to fall in love
with the sharmas and with um with
anthony and kate pardon me my lord
i never got your name
i was wondering if we'd meet again so
you might discern if my wit is
acceptable my man is genteel well i fell
in love i watched this whole season in a
day you know i was by the end of it i
was speaking in a british accent i
wasn't well it is a delicious slow burn
with a big finish this season felt like
more of a build up did you all notice
that did you know going into it and how
did you feel about holding off on the
sexiness a little bit
i mean i think it allowed us as actors
to kind of just dive into the character
development and i think it makes it
tension makes us more invested in what's
going to happen and i think it just it's
all you know it's the fireworks are even
bigger when it does all happen and it's
very earned so
yeah i was just down for it i thought
absolutely just rolling with it and
psychologically it's complicated for
these two characters there's a lot that
they have to overcome in order to get
there and there's different ways in
which you can be explicit and this feels
sort of psychologically rich and yeah um
there was so much you know that you
could nuance on the way so it's great
when they they were naked in front of
each other psychologically before they
were physically you know we fall in love
with all of them we fall even more in
love with anthony are you ready
for the fandom that's coming your way
have you gotten any advice from reggae
on how to handle being the leading man
this season and all that's to come do
you know what phoebe's been amazing and
being able to see phoebe go forward and
reggae and tell that story means that
you know we're not going to be the first
and that by no means will be the last
because there's you know six other
siblings so it's just amazing to be able
to tell the story and
and to you know we love our characters
and we want
you know it's just great to see anthony
meet kate um and so everything else that
comes with it will be fine because you
know we're surrounded by the best people
can you really not see anything engaging
about it yes i suppose i can see how he
might engage
a person
[Music]
oh my
are you hurt come now it is not proper
to stare you guys have some incredible
scenes the mud scene there are some oh
romantic horseback riding scenes any fun
stunt stories from set i mean kate you
you rear up on that horse i was a little
worried about you yeah
um oh my god
i mean movie magic um for the horse
wearing scene is all i'll say um it's
amazing what you can achieve
with um a robotic horse and i loved
filming the mud scene i thought that was
really fun yeah um although falling in
the mud just lose its novel yeah
how many takes did that take you know
what we got way too into it by the end
we were getting mud all over our face
yeah we had to re-shoot because we were
just the hysteria piglets
rolling around
but no the horse you were really
brilliant at the green screen horse
which was like this sort of giant robot
series one we had a hopper space hopper
that we had to bounce on but season two
we got a hole we actually actually had a
real we had a barrel so yeah and you
were really good at it but i got it was
like a
how cold and wet were you on rain day i
felt so sorry for you because this is
the most amazing shot the moment where
you know you you get really wet
the rain is i'm gonna say
and the rain is coming down
and um
and anyway i i was allowed to come out
and get yeah you know
i felt for you at that moment
[Music]
we have the intimacy coordinators i know
that they get creative most inventive
item used by an intimacy coordinator
goodness you know it's always it's
inventive i think it's just it's
practicality it's about protecting the
actors about creating boundaries and
making sure it's a safe environment for
us to choreograph these scenes together
and you know we we had to take it
seriously in order to have fun with it
on the day and i think we did a good job
of that i think so too yeah and the tool
kit you know it's quite pragmatic and it
has to be in order for everyone to feel
safe but there is i remember one of them
was a was it the john lewis travel
cushion oh yeah so you can get it from
john's
like a neck pillow yeah it was it was
it's got one side of it is solid and one
is soft so there we go but anyway the
tool kit will is ever expanding and it's
the difference between series one and
two and i'm sure going forward the
industry will be more and more
resourceful yeah you guys are paving the
way really you are speaking of simone
and christopher what was it like for you
it was so cool to see
elements of indian culture be brought
into this season what was that like for
you and did you kind of consult with the
writers and give them your take on it at
all we didn't get much of a say so it
was always a pleasant surprise when we
read the scripts
um and i think the thing is
what you really see are these characters
revert back to their indian culture in
times when they really need deep comfort
and in times when they want to celebrate
so i think it's like those extreme
moments they want to revert back to
what's familiar to them um but no we
didn't get much of a say but it was
always such a lovely surprise when we've
read it in the script
that was the truth yeah and we have an
indian writer in the writers room and um
you know she was the one that actually
pitched for
uh kate and edwina to be indian so very
grateful to her yeah i love that you
must be excited
this is the first chapter of a happy
story
all you have to do this evening is
remember what it is you were looking for
someone charming
and handsome of course
a prince or a duke perhaps it is not a
man's appearance or title that will woo
you it is his mind and spirit that will
caught yours
tree that you are so incredible this
season and will you be back for more
bridgerton i want to see her with the
prince now oh you're so sweet i mean
what i'd say is that bridgeton is a show
about the bridgeton family and at the
end of the day edwina's not part of that
family or she's not directly part of
that family and so she exists in the
universe she's like a sister-in-law now
yeah i mean she exists in the the bridge
of us we like to call it obviously um
with the people coming out sushi auntie
edwina
but she exists in the bridgeverse but at
the end of the day each season is about
a different bridgeton sibling and you
know
if you churro may pop up one of my
favorite relationships though is edwina
and the queen and she's got her own
spin-off yeah so we might be seeing
edwina popping up in different versions
i love that spin-up edwina and the queen
it's got a ring to it
simone and jonathan will youtube be back
because we got phoebe back we did not
get reggae will you two be back for more
bridgerton we have seasons three and
four renewed i think we we intend to be
at every wedding and and uh yeah
yeah absolutely we'll be we'll be there
for the siblings um going forward
absolutely and we're so excited as well
to support all the others in there still
love stories and that's what it's all
about and it's an amazing tv series
because i haven't really seen a series
that does this it's very special in that
sense yeah it feels like a real universe
i always think totally yeah and it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to be a
part of a family and knowing that we're
going to work together for the next 10
years is great and i feel like anthony's
just beginning really by the end of
season two there's so much more to
explore well that's a great tease
congratulations jonathan you really
delivered do you feel good about
everything i'm really excited yeah and
it's just been like you know once a
lifetime opportunity so great and also
to tell a love story i think is what the
world needs right now
[Music]
you